Bella Thorne and YouTube start Anna man
Joe make out in a series of snaps that
have us saying oh snap
[Music]
the 19 year olds up-and-coming rapper
shared several shots of herself kissing
the famous and loved actress on social
media Monday yes you work it out just 20
days after tweeting quote I want to date
at Bella Thorne X on Twitter she
captioned the puckered up pics quote
dreams do come true kids while on
Instagram she simply wrote mine
Bella also shared a pic of their makeout
sesh to Twitter asking her followers
quote who is shook tannaz response me
cuz I miss you baby
now all you guys know but this isn't the
first time we've seen them together on
Sunday the former Disney darlings shared
a video of her grabbing the vloggers
chest to snapchat
I knew my stylist the two were in tannaz
hometown Las Vegas for the three-day
like this beautiful music festival and
while it's unclear if the two are
actually dating dating in Hollywood is
literally the worst thing Bella has been
open about her sexual orientation
confirming that she's bisexual on
Twitter in 2016